oops all spideys the new trailer for
Spider-Man across the spiderverse is
lousy with wall crawlers so what did you
miss during all those blinks
the trailer is deliberately light on
villain action but what it lacks in
antagonists it more than makes up for in
spider themed Heroes clearly the wealth
of spider folks in into the spider-verse
was just a light warm-up the trailer is
packed with dozens of different spider
folks from different universes and the
task of recognizing them all will no
doubt keep fans busy for quite a while
especially because some of the cuts are
as deep as they come sure it makes sense
that we're getting a prominent spider
adjacent character like Miguel O'Hara
but did you expect to see Maybelle Riley
the steampunk influenced lady spider of
Earth 803 in there how about a spidey
who's happily rocking a version of the
bombastic Bag Man costume or perhaps
spider monkey a spidey donning the
spider armor Mark II Spider-Man
Unlimited from the 1999 TV series of the
same name the Spidey from the PS4
Spider-Man game all of them and many
many others are all present and
accounted for slinging webs and duking
it out it remains to be seen just how
deep the the movie's Cuts will be but
for a movie series that started out with
spider ham it seems that anything is
possible a huge part of the trailer is
understandably Oscar Isaac's Spider-Man
2099 AKA Miguel O'Hara the muscular
sharp fingered superhero from the future
is painted as something of a threat in
certain parts of the trailer but a
certain moment makes it clear that this
is merely a Spider-Man who has a whole
bunch on his plate we see Miguel
watching a futuristic hollow screen that
displays a happy scene of him and young
girl who appears to be called Gabriella
in the comics Miguel has a half-brother
called Gabriel So the implication here
is that the young girl is related to him
though it's not yet clear if it's his
daughter or the original character
reworked to be his much younger sister
or perhaps an orphan he's looking after
regardless of their exact familial
relation it's clear that the two are
close and the fact that we see this
happy image in the trailer implies in no
uncertain way that Gabriella plays
heavily into Miguel's motivations in the
movie
Gwen Stacy isn't the only familiar
spider person that Miles Morales finds
himself interacting with during the
trailer his old Mentor Peter B Parker
can be spied at several points in the
trailer wearing a bathrobe and sporting
what appears to be a baby carrier on his
chest has he finally become a dad after
all the ending of into the spider-verse
did see Peter realizing that maybe he
liked the idea of being a parent more
than he thought yep not only have Peter
and Mary Jane Watson healed the
fractures of their relationship but
they've also officially settled into
Parenthood even better their daughter
has been confirmed by the screenwriters
to be May Mayday Parker a fan favorite
character who if the comics are any
indication will inherit her father's
powers and one day become the amazing
Spider-Girl the Spider-Man across the
spider-verse trailer also gives us our
first look at Issa Ray's Jessica Drew
AKA Spider-Woman in a stunning new
costume that takes cues from her comic
book look while being unafraid to do
something different the character looks
to make quite the introduction as we see
her burst through a multiversal portal
on her motorcycle from the looks of
things she seems to be working closely
with Miguel O'Hara seemingly confirming
the Friendship reported on in the
footage Sony showed at cinemacon we've
known that Issa Ray was going to be
playing Spider Woman since back in 2021
when The Hollywood Reporter broke the
news and while there have been a number
of Spider Woman in the comics most
notably Julia Carpenter and Maddie
Franklin it's only fitting that Drew the
most prominent Spider-Woman of the
comics will be the one to appear first
that said expect to see a lot more of
her soon the studio is planning to make
a female lead spider vs spin-off
featuring Drew ghost spider and silk
when we get our first big reveal of the
spider-verse for Spider-Man across the
spider-verse amidst the numerous spider
people on screen we see a version of the
hero wearing a paper bag over his head
this character then returns later at
which point its parent he's animated in
a comic book art style indicative of his
comic book origin those familiar with
Spider-Man's Marvel Comics history will
recognize this as a suit that Peter
Parker wears in the issue of The Amazing
Spider-Man in which the Fantastic Four
first separate the alien venom symbiote
from Peter's body following that
procedure in the comics he wears this
goofy outfit from that point referred to
as the bombastic Bag Man in order to
disguise his identity however while the
paper bag is straight out of the comics
the rest of the outfit is different
because on the page he simply donned a
spare Fantastic Four outfit here in
across the spider-verse the bombastic
Bag Man appears in a standard Spider-Man
suit Instead This is almost definitely
because Disney now owns the movie rights
to the Fantastic Four meaning that
Spider-Man film right holder Sony can't
incorporate A Fantastic Four outfit into
their spider-verse so while the
bombastic Bag Man remains a pertinent
comic book reference the character will
be lacking his Fantastic Four Duds
probably as a simple way to avoid the
scariest threat of all legal
complications
one key moment of the trailer sees
Spider Woman take down a winged villain
this being a Spider-Man movie we all
know which bad guy has big creepy wings
and that's Adrian tombs also known as
the vulture he's an iconic foe that was
a favorite of both Sam Raimi and John
Watts it's unlikely that vulture plays a
major part in the film especially given
that vulture was already the big bad in
the recent Spider-Man film Spider-Man
homecoming still this continues a trend
from the first film of finding small
parts for all the classic members of
Spider-Man's Rogues Gallery remember how
into the spider-verse featured cameos of
such villains as Green Goblins Scorpion
and Tombstone while also giving bigger
roles to Doc Hawk Kingpin and Prowler
it's likely we'll see something similar
here this is pretty standard Spider-Man
Stakes you get used to it watch this
he's gonna say you've got 24 hours
you've got 24 hours in all fairness it's
only right that vulture makes at least
one appearance in this series the
villain has been a staple of Spider-Man
man comics since his introduction in
Amazing Spider-Man number two in 1963
where he was the first super powered foe
that Spider-Man ever faced
[Music]